la tragédie de lac-migantique a vivement
ébranlé le lien de confiance entre les
communautés vivant aux abords des voies
ferrées et l'industrie ferroviaire
Sherbrooke c'est l'état des rails les
mêmes ou à des circulé le train impliqué
dans le déraillement de Lac-Mégantic en
2013 qui ont suscité de vives
inquiétudes au lendemain de la tragédie
au niveau de la construction au niveau
de la semblait d'effectueux
mais la situation c'est depuis améliorée
le Canadien Pacifique investi des
millions depuis l'acquisition de la voie
ferrée en 2020 le risque zéro n'est
jamais présent mais je vous dirai que
par rapport au ce qu'on était moi en
tant que coordinateur des mesures
d'urgence je suis satisfait des progrès
qu'on a fait une autre amélioration les
équipes d'urgence comme celle de
Stéphane Simoneau peuvent maintenant
connaître rapidement les matières
dangereuses dans les trains en cas
d'accident grâce à cette application
lancée en 2015 un périmètre d'évacuation
peut aussi rapidement être calculée ça
va me donner 150 pieds d'évacuation par
rapport à mon positionnement
à l'échelle du pays le gouvernement
fédéral se targue d'avoir apporté de
nombreux améliorations en resserrant ces
règles depuis 2013 le ministère des
Transports a notamment augmenté de près
de 50% son nombre d'inspecteurs
effectuent davantage d'inspection le
gouvernement a aussi ordonné le retrait
progressif des wagons citerne
d'anciennes génération jugé non
sécuritaire mais Rose have benstrues
members
the breaking
Transport Canada a aussi imposé une
limite de vitesse de 56 km à l'heure au
train chargé de matière dangereuses qui
circulent dans les villes de plus de
10000 habitants
cette expert en sécurité ferroviaire
émet toutefois un bémol sur cette mesure
puisque les trains peuvent circuler à 80
km à l'heure ailleurs incluant dans les
villes de taille modeste
il juge par ailleurs que le bilan de
sécurité ferroviaire ne s'est pas
réellement amélioré malgré les
changements le nombre d'accidents voient
principal n'a pas baissé depuis 2011 au
contraire selon les données du Bureau de
la sécurité des transports
plusieurs déraillements impliquant le
déversement de millions de litres de
pétrole ont eu lieu au cours des
dernières années comme Yanné la
présidente du Bureau de la sécurité du
transport jusque la surveillance des
compagnies ferroviaires pourrait être
améliorées
Transport Canada démontre qui sont en
mesure de vérifier
l'efficacité des systèmes de de la
sécurité de la part des compagnies
Ferrières et de prendre des mesures de
façon opportune avant qu'un accident
arrive de façon à être certaine que la
compagnie est capable de gérer ses
affaires en toute sécurité il y a encore
des des étapes des mesures à prendre
pour rassurer tout le monde le système
fonctionne comme il est vrai la
militante Anne-Marie qui enquêté sur la
tragédie de lac-migantique dress quant à
elle un dur constat et je vais vous dire
il y a une seule chose qui a changé en
disant fondamentalement dans l'industrie
ferroviaire c'est les profits les
retours exponentiels aux actionnaires et
elle ne se gêne plus pour mettre au banc
des accusés les élus la loi peut faire
l'affaire ce sont les gens au pouvoir
qui ne la font pas le ministre assure
quant à lui que la sécurité et sa
préoccupation numéro 1
continue aussi d'évoluer et de nouvelles
craintes émergent à Farnham on constate
que la longueur des trains a fortement
augmenté ça fabrique la ville est en
deux pendant 30-40 minutes un enjeu pour
le maire alors que la cour du triage est
située au cœur de sa ville puis on n'est
pas à l'abri d'une tragédie si on n'est
pas à l'abri d'une tragédie au niveau du
wagon est-ce qu'on peut se dire est-ce
qu'on peut minimiser les impacts si on
enlève la cour de triage du corps urbain
on peut pas laisser statu quo ça c'est
garanti là puis moi je vais me battre
c'est sûr coriandre pour cela
l'association des chemins de fer du
Canada décliner notre demande d'entrevue
par courriel l'organisme indique que le
taux d'accident des trains des chemins
de fer de catégorie 1 soit les
compagnies ayant réalisé des recettes
d'au moins 250 millions de dollars par
année c'est améliori de 16,2% en disant
ici Thomas